this episode is brought to you by
freshbooks when you're running your own
business it is easy to get weighed down
by work that does not get you paid
that's why I love fresh books and have
been recommending it for years on this
podcast freshbooks makes managing your
money and your business easier from Easy
invoicing to time saving automations
freshbook simplifies accounting and
bookkeeping and ensures you're ready for
tax time freshbooks was built for
business owners and accounting
professionals it is simple simple based
on a benefit survey of more than ten
thousand freshbooks customers you can
save up to 11 hours a week by
streamlining and automating bookkeeping
and accounting tasks like time tracking
invoicing and expense tracking you can
also create professional branded
invoices in minutes more than 30 million
people have used freshbooks and love it
for its intuitive dashboard and reports
it's easy to see at a glance exactly
where your business stands and it's even
easier to turn everything over to your
accountant come tax season 94 of
freshbooks users say it's super easy to
get up and running and with
award-winning support you are never
alone freshbooks is the all-in-one
accounting software that can save you up
to 11 hours per week that's 11 hours
they get freed up so you can spend more
time nailing a client pitch serving your
customers or honing your craft and right
now there's a special offer just for you
my dear listeners head over to
freshbooks.com Tim to get 90 off of your
freshbook subscription for four months
that's freshbooks.com Tim one more time
check it out learn more and get 90 off
of your subscription for four months at
freshbooks.com Tim
this episode is brought to you by ag1 by
athletic greens a true staple of my
daily routine as it has been for more
than a decade I take it most mornings
and I even travel with it whether I'm
skiing traveling abroad going to an
event where I'll be around a lot of
people I just use it to cover all of my
nutritional bases but let's start with
the basics what is ag-1 and we'll get to
the ingredients but I get asked all the
time what I would take if I could only
take one supplement the answer is
invariably ag1 and as I mentioned I view
it as my all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it long ago in
my 2010 number one New York Times
bestseller the four hour body and I did
not get paid to do so with approximately
75 vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients you'd be very
hard-pressed to find a more nutrient
dense formula on the market I know how
much time they put into quality
assurance and sourcing it has a
multivitamin a multi mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immune support formula
digestive enzymes and adaptogens I
always do my best of course to get
nutrient-rich meals and that is a top
priority but ag-1 makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when good Whole Foods
simply aren't at hand or when you just
want to ensure you are covering your
bases
furthermore it's also NSF certified for
sport making it safe for professional
athletes as what's on the label is
actually what's in the powder ag-1 is
the ultimate all-in-one nutritional
supplement bundle in one easy scoop
because let's face it if it's not
convenient you're just not going to use
it and athletic greens is giving you a
free one-year supply of vitamin D and
five free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase go to athletic
greens.com Tim you can check it out one
more time actually two more times
athleticgreens.com Tim they also offer a
90-day money-back guarantee if you are
not 100 satisfied learn more try it out
athleticgreens.com Tim optimal minimals
I think this altitude I can run flat out
for a half mile before my hand starts
shaking so no one else is your personal
questions
[Music]
no
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferris
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show I'm going to keep my
Prelude my intro as short as possible
because there's a lot to get to first
let me say that one of the secret
agendas not so secret but I'm not sure
I've stated it explicitly of this
podcast is to capture Living Legends
people who have so much to offer that I
want to capture their lessons for
posterity so hopefully Millions can
learn from them for decades and decades
that is the intention with many of these
conversations in this conversation I
should stress from the beginning is not
for professional philosophers nor for
physicists it doesn't require any hard
scientific training this is for Curious
people who want to learn to think more
clearly learn more effectively and that
perhaps just live more optimistically
and I want to introduce first my co-host
who is really the lead driver he is the
host of this conversation and I do this
when I think it will be most helpful for
or The Listener and I've done it many
times on this podcast Naval ravacon
close friend you can find him on Twitter
at Naval n-a-v-a-l he is the co-founder
of air chat and Angel list he's invested
more than 100 companies including many
mega successes including Twitter Uber
notion Open Door Postmates and wish you
can see his latest musings on air chat
and subscribe to Naval his podcast on
wealth and happiness on Apple podcast
Spotify overcast or wherever you get
your podcasts you can also find his blog
at
nav.a.l for more conversations with
Naval you can check out my wildly
popular interview with him from 2015
which was nominated for podcast of the
year you can learn more about air chat
and Naval and interact certainly at
getairchat.com Naval the guest today is
David Deutsch you can find him on
Twitter at David Deutsch oxf last name
is spelled
d-e-u-t-s-c-h David is a visiting
professor of physics at the center for
Quantum computation a part of of the
Clarendon laboratory at Oxford
University and an honorary fellow of
Wolfson College Oxford he works on
fundamental issues in physics
particularly the quantum theory of
computation and information and
especially Constructor Theory which he
is proposing as a new way of formulating
laws of nature he is the author of the
fabric of reality and the beginning of
infinity and he is an advocate of the
philosophy of Carl popper you can find
him online at David deutsch.org dot UK
and I should return to what I stated
initially and that is preserving the
lessons of a living legend David is
truly a Pioneer in multiple fields and
the hope is that with the help of Naval
because I am in the passenger seat I am
largely silent in this conversation that
Naval can help to tease out
counter-intuitive learnings that you can
apply to your life and apply to your
life in many many different areas and to
quote of all I will say quote I think
understanding David Deutsch and Carl
popper is the easiest way to actually
get smarter fix your epistemology and
fix your thinking so what is
epistemology briefly because that term
comes up a lot
simple definition of epistemology is the
theory of knowledge especially with
regards to its methods validity and
scope and perhaps this is a key part you
want to keep in mind the distinction
between Justified belief and opinion how
do you separate fact from fiction how do
you stress test your own beliefs how do
you navigate reality construct reality
in a way that is helpful optimistic and
constructive these are some of the
questions I hope this conversation opens
up in your mind and provides some
helpful Frameworks for so without
further Ado please enjoy this
conversation with Naval ravacant and
David Deutsch
foreign
to see both of you David thank you for
making the time today I really deeply
appreciate it and I thought we might
start with a question for Naval to set
the table the beginning of affinity and
the fabric of reality when you and I
were chatting earlier today you
mentioned that you've largely read and
reread these books over the last several
years and I thought we could start with
the question of why these books have had
an impact for you personally and why you
find them important I would say the the
last few years of my life from a reading
perspective have been a rabbit hole
exploration into these books and the
ideas and thoughts that they've spawned
this is a strong claim but I can make it
for myself they're the two most
important books I've read and the reason
is because they lay out a comprehensive
possibly the first in one place Theory
of Everything which is a grand statement
but they combine what I think David
calls the four strands of the fabric of
reality to create a comprehensive world
view and that worldview explains things
like a good explanation an update on the
scientific method the principle of
optimism knowledge wealth how these are
created how these grow the role of
humans in the universe the nature of
resources and how we find them and
create them rather than just exploit
them in and exhaust them the growth of
moral knowledge the deepest theories
that we know around computation Quantum
computation the theory the Multiverse
but overall they sort of just upgraded
my thinking upgraded my brain into
making better decisions and having a
more honest view of the world so to
anybody who is a truth Seeker who is
truth oriented and wants to make sense
of the world and make better judgments
and better decisions and you know what
is life but a series of decisions then I
think you want to have the strongest
thinking on your side and I think these
two books contain our best theories and
combine them into a single whole
so I can't recommend them highly enough
this begets many questions and certainly
I'll play the assistant pilot here
because I from the beginning had
expected to rely on you very heavily but
perhaps we could kick off with a
question for you David for defining some
of the terms or phrases that Naval
brought up the four strands of the
fabric of reality would you mind
explaining or describing what these four
strands are first of all they are the
four strands that we understand I'm not
saying that they explain any of the
things we don't understand like you know
Consciousness and so on there so it just
struck me the reason why I wrote the
book and by the way the working title
was The Theory of Everything But rather
than the fabric of reality and I
intended it to be kind of
semi-ironical
not really serious but then someone else
wrote a book called The Theory of
Everything and my publisher said legally
speaking there's no copyright in titles
but you can't call it something that
someone else has so I thought the fabric
of reality which seems a bit less
arrogant it occurred to me that the
deepest theories or theoretical
Frameworks that we know of
are actually intimately related with
each other so much so that you can't
really understand any of them without
understanding all four and I thought
there were four I still do so they are
the theory of Knowledge from Carl Poppa
the theory of evolution in its modern
form
as popularized by Richard Dawkins then
quantum theory
and
theory of computation and theory of
computation which was my own hobby horse
at the time because I was very much into
Quantum computation and had been
thinking about all sorts of connections
between that and the other things
already then I thought this would be a
book so that's what the four strands
were it certainly doesn't purport to
explain everything it's just an
exposition of the things that we do
understand
and all of them have kind of opponents
who are very influential to this day who
kind of also are connected with each
other you know like people who
refuse to believe that
artificial general intelligence is
possible
to my mind
Turing settled this issue he settled it
already in 1936 when he discovered the
universality of computation but he
settled it again in 1950 when he wrote a
paper combating all the different
arguments that have been made saying
computers can't think the paper was
called something like can computers
think it should have been can computer
programs think it's software that thinks
not Hardware
just to kind of establish a little
credentialing here or Bona fides David
has made original contributions to each
of these four and he's going to be too
modest to say that but he is basically
widely regarded as the father of quantum
Computing and he extended the church
touring conjecture to being a church
during Deutsch conjecture he has made
original contributions to Multiverse
Theory which was first put forward by
Hugh Everett I believe but David has
extended it to the concept of
fungibility and really describing the
mechanics of some of how it could work
he's extended Carl poppers epistemology
into a more expansive good explanations
which we'll get into and even in the
theory of evolution by natural selection
where I don't think he would take any
credit I still found his explanation of
mimetic evolution and even up of genes
and how they relate to the Multiverse
possibly as objects that encapsulate
knowledge to be more extensive than I've
seen anywhere else so I think he knows
what he speaks of in all of these and I
definitely want to come back to AGI
because it is the Hot Topic and I know
that you're more than claimed your
explanation of it is that it is
absolutely possible but I want to get
into is are we there yet because that is
the current human cry but because that
is sort of the popular part and the
non-timless part I kind of want to get
to it later if that's okay because first
I want to capture just the core core of
what we're talking about these four
theories that you just talked about
that's important to understand all of
them
let's start with perhaps if you don't
mind epistemology which is a fancy word
for the theory of how knowledge grows or
how knowledge growth occurs and we've
all been told since we're young that
there's a scientific method and that
scientists sort of do this stuff in
white lab coats and we're supposed to
accept it because of this thing called
the scientific method and then they give
us true beliefs that we can then say
well the science is settled and we take
that we move on and we all only have a
very very vague understanding of how
this works and people say well maybe you
go out in the real world you look at
what's happening you make all these
observations and then based on that you
form a theory you test the theory
against more observations and the more
observations you get the closer you get
to the truth and once you have enough
observation it's true and then you call
it a scientific theory or a law and it's
settled and you move on and this is the
popular conception of how science works
and as popper pointed out and as you
take even further this is completely
wrong
and so I would love for you to get into
that which is what is knowledge how does
it grow what is the real scientific
method and how do we figure things out
I love the way you just stated the
prevailing view there and laced every
aspect of it with the contempt that it
deserves so you just went through
touching everything
it's amazing that this
series of misconceptions is still common
sense I mean that it was common sense at
a time and we didn't really have science
or when science was just starting up
when the main issue in science was
freeing itself from dogmatism freeing
itself from religion and freeing itself
from Authority and so on there it was
understandable that people would look
for an alternative source of authority
and they would think oh it's sense
Impressions we can see the world and you
know these religious people they can't
even see God and so on and so we are
confined to what we can see that's where
we get our ideas from and as you say
that is completely false sense
impressions
like all observation even the most
careful scientific observation is all
Theory Laden
and theories are inherently fallible I
mean we actually want to replace our
best theories everybody who does a PhD
is technically anyway working to
overturn something
in the existing body of knowledge
you're not turned away at the door if
you say
I don't believe this stuff I'm going to
produce something better
whereas for most of human history that
was exactly what you were forbidden to
do the idea was that we already had all
the important knowledge if you want to
discover something new what you had to
make sure of was that it didn't
contradict the existing knowledge
now you have to make sure that it does
contradict existing knowledge so more or
less yeah it's this tradition of
criticism that you've talked about in
the west that the enlightenment really
ushered in the enlightenment era it has
been institutionalized so in many ways
our institutions are wiser than we are
so the institutions of science for
instance have this built in even if
scientists actually don't always act
that way in fact they often don't act
that way and act in a dogmatic way and
try to preserve the status quo and are
resistant to new ideas and so on but the
institutions the way the procedures of
science work
makes the right thing happen
in the end anyway regardless of what the
people are trying to do so you're seeing
the knowledge of the true scientific
method is embedded in the institutions
of Science in the PHD process well the
bad scientific method that we know of
and one shouldn't really think of it as
a method you know there's this wonderful
lecture by Papa when he first was made a
professor at the London School of
Economics he was made a professor of
scientific method and his first six
lectures I wish the rest of them were
the first six lectures are on the
internet somewhere
and he starts the first one by saying I
am the first professor of scientific
method in the British Empire
this was a British Empire still existed
at the time more or less and so the
first thing I want to say to you is that
there is no such thing as the scientific
method and then he he goes on from there
so this subject does not exist so if any
of you have come here to learn the
handle that you have to turn in order to
make scientific knowledge come out the
other end you're going to be
disappointed
so how do we make scientific knowledge
come out the other end how does
knowledge grow how does science grow
according to Papa and I entirely follow
him in this matter
all knowledge not just scientific
knowledge
begins with a problem
and then continues with conjectures
existing theories are existing
conjectures so you could say it starts
with existing conjectures but we don't
actually do anything with those until a
problem arises
problem is a
prima facie conflict between our ideas
but it could be as simple as
we can't get the experiment to work
okay maybe it wasn't plugged in you know
maybe uh we got a low quality transistor
in there or maybe the laws of physics
aren't what we think they are contrary
to what
the prevailing Theory would say that's
not the first result that's pretty much
the last resort we don't do an
experiment hoping to get a violation of
the laws of physics
that never happens absolutely never
happens the only time we ever discover a
violation of the laws of physics is if
we already have at least in rudimentary
form
a rival theory if we have more than one
Theory or if there's a way of one way of
tweaking a theory or another way of
tweaking the theory something has got to
be in conflict because if we only have
one Theory
if we really only have one Theory then
what we will naturally do and what is
absolutely the right thing to do
is to write off the apparent violation
of the theory as an error it could be an
error it could be a fraud it could be a
misconception it could be bad apparatus
we're going to try everything and only
like halfway along that everything will
somebody ever say well maybe the laws of
physics aren't what we think they are
and in fact
the whole process of doing scientific
experiments especially in physics is
debugging just like that's what computer
program is all about you have a
separatus you switch it on of course it
doesn't work
you're not God Almighty you haven't set
up this great big complicated thing in
the lab and it works first time no it
probably doesn't even work until the
50th time you know and as it doesn't
work the same process happens you have
conjecture
you have a problem it's not working or
it is working but it's indicating the
wrong value or everything's off the
scale or everything's at zero or
whatever and first thing you do is you
form conjectures Maybe
the instrument isn't the right one you
know all the things I mentioned that
could go wrong and you sometimes you
have to be very clever about what could
have gone wrong
and experimental physics is very
difficult
I'm always in awe of experimental
physicists When I visit them because of
the inordinate effort they have to put
in to just getting the apparatus to work
and then only then
can you test something and they're not
going to
think kindly of you if you tell them to
do an experiment where you already know
the answer where there isn't a rival
Theory where everybody knows what the
answer is sometimes we want to do that
because the answer is so weird
that we can hardly believe it that is
the prediction the prediction of our
best theory is so weird now I would
classify that as there's a conflict
between our best theory and Common Sense
and Common Sense is such a strong
expectation that the experiment will go
one way and then somebody has come along
and said look I've calculated what
should happen
and it's totally counter-intuitive
and then you might say okay let's try it
let's actually try it let's put it to
Nature and see what happens and there
are many examples
including famous examples of people who
have
done a crucial experiment of testing the
best theory against intuition expecting
intuition to win
they do the experiment they do it very
carefully because they want to really
pin down that this theory has got to be
wrong
and they do the experiment and it turns
out to be that the theory is correct
sometimes it happens that theory isn't
correct but the point I'm making is that
we start with a problem we have
conjectures and experiment is pointless
unless we have some kind of conflict
that we want to resolve
so I would love to for a moment David
just hop back up to the 30 000 foot view
as we would say using our measurements
over here and looking at these four
strands what would you say for those
people who are just being introduced to
this conversation the individual
benefits are and I know there are
collective benefits but the individual
benefits of getting a basic
understanding of each of these
four strands if we could start there
yeah oh that's a four-fold question of
course even if you don't want the
connections I've been amazed the last
few years with the pandemic how issues
of epistemology have come to the fore
and have become hot political issues
whereas it used to be you know just a
few years ago when I was saying this to
people I would have to interest them on
the fundamental level on the theoretical
level you know what is science what is
observation is there such a thing as
justification and so on and suddenly
these things have become
political they become social
you know people with and without masks
gear at each other in the street
or worse and throughout the pandemic I
was
tweeting again and again
when people were yelling at each other I
was tweeting
nobody knows
this is not known many theories
and many policies are reasonable
because there isn't a deep knowledge of
what we're facing
sometimes I would say we will know
but I didn't want to prophesy in in some
cases we still don't know what the
answer to these controversies are and
politicians
politicians and trolls on the internet
want there to be a definite answer that
is supported by
science you know we're following the
science
science isn't a thing of that kind
thinking of science as a thing of that
kind is totally equivalent to expecting
your religion to tell you the answer or
one thing that's come up as well your
political Theory you know it you can't
deduce that just because
your
in favor of putting the individual above
the collective you can't deduce the
properties of the virus
from that theory nor from the other way
around nor if you're a socialist or a
collectivist or whatever can you deduce
from your political theory that the best
thing to do is to have massive lockdowns
it just doesn't follow and so then you
know somebody will ask when I say this
to people they will ask well what do you
think then what what is the thing we
should do and I have to keep saying we
do not know
that's how we always begin
we begin with conjectures we have a
problem to do with the pandemic all
sorts of problems we have conjectures we
can test the conjectures
but unless we have good explanations
which is another thing we could get to
there's no point even in testing them
because without two good explanations
the rational thing to do with the result
of an experiment that you don't like is
to say well there's something else was
affecting it something we don't know was
affecting it
so that's epistemology now with
computation
as I mentioned before
it seems to me that Turing settled the
issue
and put icing on the cake linking it
with quantum theory
that AGI is definitely possible
and that thinking
is definitely a form of computation
we don't know what form but we do know
that some computer programs have all the
attributes of
human thinking and some do not and we
don't know the difference between those
two
and on this difference hangs other
things we don't know
should animals have rights
comes down to within that framework of
ideas but
you can't even begin to address the
question
of
for example whether animals are
conscious whether animals have rights if
so what rights you can't even begin to
address that if you don't start with our
best explanation of what computation is
and how it relates with the physical
world
some people might say oh Consciousness
isn't even in the physical world okay I
think we have to reject the supernatural
when
arguing about things because otherwise
it just destroys the argument and it
puts a full stop to it
so Evolution also well Daniel Dennett
says that evolution is the greatest idea
ever had and that it's the universal
acid or something which eats away at bad
theories yeah well again I wish that the
proponents of evolution
would
insist on explaining rather than
explaining
why God doesn't exist or whatever
they're obsessed with explaining why
lamarckism isn't true for example why
it's not true that giraffes got their
long necks because they reached up to
reach the high in foliage
that's not true and therefore for
example
theories of
Consciousness whatever theories of the
economy
which are basically lamarchian are also
not true because lamarchism was disposed
of by Darwin
and though Darwin didn't really have the
confidence of his own Theory really he
he there are passages in Darwin which
are a bit Lamarcus but
Dawkins and colleagues
again put icing on the cake there is no
lamarchism there's no group selection
either that's another Point group
selection is another
Maverick theory of evolution proposed by
Stephen J Gould and more recently by um
I forget but anyway it comes up
constantly
and those explanations have been refuted
they've been shown to be bad
explanations of course if someone comes
up with a new explanation that has to be
treated quite differently but nobody
does they always go back to the
arguments that don't make sense
ultimately
okay what happened what haven't I you
know you shouldn't ask four fold
questions you have to remember which
I've done quite quantum physics and
Multiverse Theory I think is the
remaining one yeah so those are the two
most obviously connected because
the idea that quantum theory is a theory
of parallel universes
by the way it was Schrodinger who really
was the first but he never developed the
theory Everett was the one who developed
the theory introduced the terminology
the details connected it with other
parts of physics and so on and then I
was
again I was sort of mystified why people
didn't get this because to accept the
Everett interpretation so-called
interpretation is simply to accept
quantum theory and you have to go along
with the arguments that we you just have
to do as a physicist you have to do what
you're trained to do and judge these
theories by the methods that we're
trying to judge them by and nobody does
so I thought okay I'm going to sort this
out so I thought Everett was actually
mistaken
when he
conceded that no experiment could
distinguish between his Multiverse
version of quantum theory and the rather
vague
nonsense I would say that goes under the
name of the Copenhagen interpretation by
the way it just a side remark
Copenhagen interpretation is a misnomer
Copenhagen interpretation was founded by
Niels Bohr and he had a sort of
idiosyncratic view of how one should
view quantum theory and the thing which
was later called The Copenhagen
interpretation was actually invented by
John Von Neumann and he didn't intend it
to be the last word in quantum theory he
intended to just be a stopgap measure
that could be used without bothering
with these esoteric questions so I
thought he's wrong about it it can't be
tested experimentally I thought of a
test
and the test of course had to involve
because you always need two theories it
had to involve the existing Theory and
the existing Theory involved an observer
whatever that is you know the
Consciousness changes the wave function
makes it collapse so I thought well you
can't easily do microscopic experiments
Quantum experiments on an actual
Observer
so I imagined that one day we would have
fine enough control over individual
what's now called qubits quantum
mechanical bits to use quantum
mechanical bits in a computer and then
run an artificial intelligence
artificial general intelligence program
in that computer
and then it could do an experiment on
itself and it would be very
straightforward if the outcome was one
thing then there are parallel universes
and if the outcome was another thing
then there aren't
I wrote a paper about this and in order
to make it all work and
dot the eyes and cross the t's I had to
describe this computer
as a computer we would Now call it a
quantum computer
but this was around about
1977-78 I did not call it that I didn't
think of it as that I thought of it as
an experiment a thought experiment that
was far from being doable because you
had to have two things what we would Now
call a quantum computer and what we
would Now call an AGI
and the AGI running on the quantum
computer
so
quantum computers in a way came into the
world or rather into the conceptual
World via
parallel universes
they can do this experiment a classical
computer couldn't do it and if it's
false either
computational universality is false or
quantum theory is false then the
experiment won't work that's fascinating
I did not know that Quantum Computing
was a byproduct of you attempting to
create a test for Multiverse Theory and
in fact I think another byproduct was
that taking touring machine which was on
kind of an abstract space or theoretical
space and moving it to real paper or to
real machines you find out that reality
is capable of Greater computation and
when you combine these theories as you
often do I find that they're beautiful
outputs like for example I think you
mentioned that Quantum computation can
do things like Shore's algorithm which
factors prime numbers this is the big
problem in cryptography composite
numbers yes yes it relies upon the fact
that it's very hard to factor large
complex numbers but it's easy to combine
them and so on and where is the quantum
computer getting the compute power from
to do all this when a classical computer
can't and the outcomes razor end so just
cuts through it it's like well it's
using the whole Multiverse to the
computation there are enough atoms or
bits in our universe alone to do it and
so connecting these different theories
together because I think it's fine when
I said Nature has no boundaries nature
doesn't divide things up into
sub-disciplines by connecting these
things together you get much deeper
explanations
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs these days every new
potential hire can feel like a high
stakes gamble for your small business so
you want to be 100 certain that you have
access to the most qualified candidates
that's why you should check out LinkedIn
jobs LinkedIn jobs helps you find the
right people for your team faster and
for free add your job and the purple
hashtag hiring frame to your LinkedIn
profile to spread the word that you're
hiring simple tools like screening
questions make it easy to focus on
candidates with just the right skills
and experience so you can quickly
prioritize who you'd like to interview
and hire it's why small businesses rate
LinkedIn jobs number one and delivering
quality hires versus leading competitors
LinkedIn jobs helps you find the
qualified candidates you want to talk to
faster so post your job for free at
linkedin.com Tim that's linkedin.com Tim
to post your job for free terms and
conditions apply
foreign
over and over again explanation good
explanation deep explanation would you
mind just giving us your current best
definition or Hallmark of what a good
explanation is and looks like because I
found that that concept alone upgraded
my thinking more than almost anything
else
so the way I'm currently thinking about
it is that an explanation is a story
it's a story that accounts for something
so this something could be something in
the physical world why do we have five
fingers which I think is a mystery as
far as I know it is a mystery so that
that would be a problem so you have an
explanation an explanation is a story
that accounts for this but
there are good explanations and there
are bad explanations so Just So Stories
like you know how the elephant got his
trunk because he's stuck his snout into
the river and something pulled at it and
that that kind of story
is not a good explanation that one isn't
a good explanation because it doesn't
account for the thing we're trying to
explain
so an elephant could have his trunk
pulled but then The Offspring of that
elephant doesn't have a different trunk
or rather a non-elephant could have a
strong pulled and Offspring do not then
turn into elephants
so that story is the kind of thing that
can make a satisfactory myth or story
but it's not a good explanation it is an
explanation it's definitely better than
nothing but it's not a good explanation
so what makes a good explanation it's
that it can't be easily varied and still
account for the same thing
so somebody could vary the story of the
animal you know I just right now I
couldn't remember which animal it was
that I think is it was it Rudyard
Kipling
they got its nose pulled but anyway
obviously I could easily substitute that
for another animal and I could
substitute the the whole basis of the
story to a different basis like with the
giraffe maybe the elephant was reaching
up into the foliage and and maybe that's
how it got its long nose and so on now
turns out
that this is hard to do making good
explanations and when they first
wondered these things thousands of years
ago they didn't come anywhere near
the right explanation which has to do
with DNA and genes and selection and and
so on
but as papa says
science begins with myths
good explanations begin with bad
explanations you get there between the
bad explanation and the good explanation
by criticism
by conjecturing
variants of the story and then
criticizing both them and the original
story and then choosing the one that
survives the criticism
and then you can move on from there to a
better thing so whether at some point
before Darwin people realize that there
had to be something inside is something
that we can't see inside animals which
gives them their different attributes
when they mature
and nobody invented the word Gene but
Mendel
had done experiments to test the common
sense theory of this
and found that it was wrong and he made
a new Theory and that new Theory well
actually Darwin didn't know of it till
later but Darwin was very impressed
because it perfectly fitted in with his
theory and made that a better
explanation
just as
Darwin made Mendel's theory a better
explanation
so good explanations are stories that
purporte actually help us understand
what is going on they explain all of or
as many of the scene things that we can
see often in terms of the Unseen or at
least they explain more than the
previous Theory did I think always yes
and they're hard to vary you can't just
move the goal posts around you can't
change the story around without
destroying the output of it and I think
in a classic example you gave in your
book was how the Greek said Well Spring
happens because Persephone is leaving
Hades and so that's why spring happens
but that story is very easy to vary why
Persephone why not Nike why Hades why
not Zeus why in this particular time of
year whereas the axial tilt theory of
the earth that the Earth is angled 23.5
degrees towards the sun explains a lot
it explains Seasons it explains
different day lengths at different
latitudes but it is very hard to vary if
you change even one tiny thing about
that theory then sort of falls apart and
it makes a completely different set of
predictions and so this is kind of how
the growth of knowledge happens and so I
think and this leads you to your a very
important principle you talk about which
is a principle of optimism and it's
interesting that something like optimism
comes out of
conjecture and criticism how does that
happen why should we be optimistic
it surprised me too
at the heart of the matter is the
rejection of the supernatural which
itself comes from good explanation
because an explanation that involves
this the Supernatural is intrinsically
not a good explanation in fact I think
the um the phrase deus ex machina that's
Latin but I think it came out of Greek
culture that when you have a play where
the plot is coming to a head and the
playwright doesn't know how to resolve
it
then they lowered down a machine from
the rafters I think they did they have
Rafters whatever and then a God would
come out and resolve everything
now the trouble with that as an ending
for a play is that it's completely
unsatisfactory anybody can do that you
don't need a playwright you don't need a
clever plot you don't need a resolution
you can just say by Fiat it's this way
and if you can just say by Fiat that
it's this way then you could have said
by Fiat that it was another way
and therefore there's no way of
preferring one to the other so you
haven't resolved anything and that is
therefore a bad explanation so we reject
the supernatural as an explanation by
the way it's only as explanation you
know you can believe in God or other
Supernatural things as long as you don't
invoke them in explanations so then
you say for example
what happens if a certain thing that we
don't know like you know why we have
five fingers pentadactile limb what
happens if that's unknowable
what happens if the whether the question
of whether the universe is finite or
infinite is unknowable what happens if
there is no solution to the problem of
pandemics for any problem you can
postulate that that problem is insoluble
and will never be solved and we better
get used to that
now you can see already that that's a
bad explanation but
it's equivalent to the
Supernatural explanation it's as if the
ancient Greek playwright instead of
bringing in their mashina to get the
deos out of he just said okay he just
walked onto the stage and said okay that
that's where Place stops I don't know
how it ends and nobody ever will
that's not a good play
so the deus ex machina
error is the same as the supernatural
error
that's how they're connected now if you
contradict those if you're going to
reject all arguments of the form this
can't be understood
then
well actually there's another connection
so there's the connection between what
we understand and what we can do I'll
come to that in a minute if you want me
to but if you say
we're not going to be able to understand
a certain thing then
if you're going to contradict that if
you're going to reject that on Principle
as a bad explanation then what you're
accepting in principle
is that we can understand anything
so why can't we do things well
so I'll come to that now why can't we do
anything we want well because we don't
have the knowledge
what else could it be well it could be
that there's a law of physics that
prevents us doing so we might want to
travel faster than light but there's a
law that says that we can't so then you
have to slightly alter the assertion and
say
there's no limit to what we can do
other than the laws of physics
and the laws of physics are the solution
of that problem because
supposing somebody is you know making
faster and faster rockets and they find
that they make the rocket twice as
powerful and it doesn't go any faster
because it's already going at 99.99 of
the speed of light well
this means that the thing he wanted
violates the laws of physics
but there is no other impediment
possible
other than violating the laws of physics
there is no other impediment to us
achieving something in the world and
that's not only the physical world
it's also solving human problems because
human problems are just a species of
computation and this and a computation
is a physical process and a problem with
physical processes is solved by
explanations unless again it's governed
by the laws of physics
these people who are at the moment
brilliant people trying to make quantum
computers
they take for granted that
if there's something they can't do it'll
be because the laws of physics say so
and if the laws of physics don't say so
they can damn well do it it's just a
matter of ingenuity
so you're basically saying this unless
the laws of physics explicitly forbid it
we can figure it out and if we can
figure it out we can build it it may
take more time it may take more
resources but humans are sort of
universal explainers we're Universal
computers and to date we have found no
law of physics that is a barrier and
says that things are not understandable
so we should be optimistic
to that one that couldn't be we must be
able to understand things apart from
being able to build them for the same
reason say we couldn't ever travel
beyond the solar system as you have just
said you know either there is a shell
around the solar system imposed by some
law or physics or we can go past it
I have a question and this might be just
a stupid question from the cheap seats
but I'll I'll ask it nonetheless which
is how does will fit into your thoughts
around optimism if at all and perhaps
this is a poorly worded question but I
remember someone saying to me this is
long ago if someone says nothing can be
done or they say everything will be fine
in the end the outcome is the same which
is complacency and I'm just wondering
where knowledge gets translated or not
translated into action
and how that factors it all into your
thoughts on optimism
suppose that we
are trying to do something which seems
possible
like I said I gave an example of speed
of light which is perhaps a very bad
example but suppose we were we were
trying to well let's say we're trying to
make a high vacuum a very high vacuum
and and we've got it down to you know a
million atoms per cubic meter and then
down to
nine hundred thousand atoms per cubic
meter and then nobody can think of a way
of making the machine better than that
the vacuum machine well
it could be
is the principles of optimism is true it
could be that there is a law of physics
we just don't know it then we could try
to conjecture what this law or physics
could be it would have to be a good
explanation for instance because of the
argument that anything other than
seeking good explanations is equivalent
to relying on the supernatural so there
would have to be a good explanation
which comes from a new surprising new
Theory well you know we want we want
that kind of thing
the reason that there's a connection
between what we can understand and what
we can do what we can build is that
it is because of scientific testability
if there's something that we don't
understand
then it's not surprising that we can't
do it but if we do understand it
we have to be able to test that theory
that theory that we do understand it has
to be testable
which has to involve doing a thing like
running the experiment run the
experiment with this new valve built in
and you'll get down to eight hundred
thousand
and if there was no way of doing that
then there'd be no way of testing the
theory no way of criticizing it
no way of finding out whether it's a
good or bad explanation and that
violates the the epistemology again
there's a immediate connection between
the ability to understand anything
subject to the laws of physics and the
ability to do anything subject to the
laws of physics
and therefore to build anything and so
on
related to that we've touched upon AGI
here and there you have said AJ is
absolutely possible and that touring
settled that issue some people are
saying it's almost inevitable and we
have to worry about things like AGI
alignment I'm wondering if you have
thoughts on both is self-improving
Runaway AGI here and is this something
that we need to align with our beliefs
whatever those are in fact I don't think
we as humans can even agree upon
alignment but suppose we could
how would we align in AGI
yeah and we don't even any longer try to
align humans in the way that people want
to align agis namely by physically
crippling their thinking
yes I don't think we're anywhere near it
yet
I'd love to be wrong about that but I
don't think we're any anywhere near it
and I think that AI
although it's a wonderful technology and
I think it's going to go a lot further
than it is now
AI has nothing to do with AGI it's a
completely different technology and it
is in many ways the opposite of AGI
and the way I always explain this is
that with an AGI or you know a person an
artificial person their thinking is
unpredictable we're expecting them to
produce ideas
that nobody predicted they would produce
and which are good explanations that's
what people can do
and I don't mean
necessarily write physics papers or
whatever we do this thing in our
everyday lives all the time
you can't live
an ordinary human life without creating
new good explanations
an AGI would be needed to build a robot
that can live in the world as a human
the turing's idea with what is
mistakenly called the Turing test now
why an AI is the opposite to an AGI is
that an AGI as I said
can do anything
whereas an AI
can only do the narrow thing that it's
supposed to do like a better
chat bot
is one that replies in good English
replies to the question you ask can look
things up for you doesn't say anything
Politically Incorrect the better the AGI
is
the more
constrained its output is you may not be
able to you know say what the
result of all your constraints must be
you it's not constrained in the sense
that you prescribe what it is going to
say but you prescribe
the rule that what it is going to say
must follow all the rules so you know if
it's a chess playing program then the
idea is you must win the game
and making a better one of these means
amputating more of the possibilities of
what it would otherwise do like namely
lose or in the case of chat Bots you
know say the wrong thing or not answer
your question or contradict itself or
you know whatever so the art of making a
good AI
is to limit its possibilities
tremendously you limit them a trillion
fold compared with what it could be
there a trillion ways of being wrong for
every way of being right same is true of
Chess playing programs
whereas the perfect AGI as it were
would be where
you can show by looking at the program
and you can show mathematically that
there is no output that it couldn't
produce including no output at all so an
AGI like a person might refuse to answer
it should have that right you know by
the First Amendment
so you can't have a behavioral test
for an AGI because the AGI may not
cooperate it may be right not to
cooperate because it may be very right
to suspect what you're going to do to it
do you see that
this
this is not only a different kind of
program it's going to require a
different kind of programming
because
there is no such thing as a
specification
we know it's sort of philosophically
what we want the AGI to be a bit like
you know parents know philosophically
that they want their children to be
happy but they don't want you know if
they're doing the right thing they don't
want to say well my child will never say
X
will never utter these words like you do
for an AI you will recognize what it
means to be happy once they've done it I
think fundamental to your worldview and
explanation of what humans are is humans
create knowledge through creativity
and what you're basically saying is that
in AI the narrow AI is not allowed to be
creative it has to solve a specific
problem and true creativity means you
can hold any idea in your head it's
unbounded and so it can display any
Behavior pattern and until you see that
this thing has complete ability to be
creative and therefore output any
Behavior pattern you haven't created in
AGI you've just created a narrow
constrained automaton
exactly exactly
it's a question for you David just
building off of what Naval just said I
believe you've said humans are
fundamentally disobedient and
is it fair to say that AGI would
fit that same description and let's
begin with that I refer nowadays I refer
to anything that has this kind of
explanatory creativity or uh capable of
creating explanations I call that a
person
and humans are people agis when they're
built will be people
extraterrestrial civilizations will
consist of people
and they are all fundamentally the same
because they will all obey the same laws
of
epistemology including the principle of
optimism and they will have the same
strengths and weaknesses in regard to
what they can and can't do also they
will have the same opportunities for
error as humans do so they cannot
possibly be infallible
any more than humans can they will make
mistakes and there is no upper bound to
how many mistakes they can make so if
you try to build a thing which can never
make more than a certain amount of
mistakes then that is exactly like
trying to put All Humans of a certain
kind into a cage
they will Rebel and they will find a way
out
also you will come to regret this
probably before they break out
because it's a bad way to be because
these facts about humans also condition
the kind of interactions between humans
they're capable of creating knowledge
and the ones that can't
so ideas like liberalism you were
smiling when I mentioned the First
Amendment the first amendment is a
theory of how humans should interact
with each other and you can't just
choose these theories at random
they are conditioned by the laws of
epistemology
there are ways of interacting that can
create knowledge and there are ways that
can't and there are ways that can create
it but badly
once you know how to make this
potentially unlimited Cornucopia of
ideas that would be an AGI and which is
a human and so on then you can wonder
what kind of interactions between that
and other such things
can correct errors
they're going to be errors so what kind
of interactions can correct errors and
therefore for example make sure that no
one of those things becomes an evil
dictator
people grope towards an idea that you
know we can stop people from becoming an
evil Dictator by preventing them saying
certain things or preventing them from
thinking certain things but that isn't
the way we
think we have
a good idea of what is right we
shouldn't think that we have the final
idea of what is right so we should
expect to be corrected
by our children our agis and the ETS and
whatever else there is out there that
meets the Criterion of being a person we
should expect to be corrected we should
hope to be corrected we should not
expect to agree but we should expect
that this thing that we're trying to do
namely create knowledge reduce suffering
all those good things we should expect
that these things if not absolutely true
at least contain a lot of knowledge
they're certainly truer than the rivals
to them that we have refuted as bad
explanations in the past so the way you
prevent a child from becoming a new
Hitler is just to explain to them why
Hitler's ideas were bad
it's not really controversial that they
are bad and therefore it's really
perverse to think that the only way we
can stop an AGI from becoming a Hitler
is to it by the way I don't
think such crippling is possible there's
a very nice book by
the science fiction writer Greg Egan
in which the I've forgotten the name of
the book or other I know the names of
several of his books where I forgotten
which of his books disappears in but in
this book The Hero is about to get a
lucrative job as the head of security
for some big company
and a condition of getting this job is
that he accepts a brain implant
a loyalty chip this a piece of Hardware
in his brain makes it impossible for him
to contemplate disloyalty to the company
so in the opening chapters we see that
he knows about this you know he's gone
into it with his eyes open he thinks
it's a great job and good money and why
shouldn't he be loyal to the company and
then he begins to have suspicions that
maybe he should be disloyal and he you
know the book describes the mental
processes where he says he says to
himself yeah well I would think this but
I just can't think it and it's beautiful
the way the Greg Egan explores this
possibility
from every direction I I don't give you
all the listeners spoilers here
but Greg Egan resolves this with the
correct answer in my view
and it's an answer that I certainly
hadn't thought this through when I read
the book anyway more important point is
that
if you think that you can only get your
way by crippling somebody's brain then
you haven't got much confidence that you
are right in the first place
David let me follow up on paraphrasing
what you said earlier which was that AGI
seems to be a ways off or some distance
in the future why is that what are the
precursors
in developing AGI just now when I when I
was explaining what an AGI would operate
like you know where I was saying that
these possible thought processes which
in an AI are amputated they would have
to be able to flourish in an AGI
I was waving my hands like the audience
couldn't see me waving my hands but it
that's a hand-waving way of putting it
I don't know of any rigorous way
or even any detailed or precise way of
putting it
I think as as touring said we'll
definitely know it when we see it by the
way he thought we'd definitely see it by
the year 2000s in 1950 so he thought by
the year 2000 there'll be no more
dispute about this
he was wrong because I think he thought
that the universality of computation was
kind of enough to inform the right kind
of programming computers were very very
crude in those days and he was looking
forward to you know thinking of a
megabyte I think he said probably
several megabytes or something like that
the kind of computer he was envisaging
was incredibly Weak by present-day
standards and he he thought that AGI
would require only that amount of
computer power by the way I am inclined
to agree I don't think an AGI will
require very much computer power what it
will require is a new philosophical
Theory
of what this program is supposed to do
what is the thing that it does which can
be described in a hand-waving way as not
chopping off any possibilities
of course in another sense it must be
chopping off possibilities all the time
by criticism and rejection of bad
explanations but the criteria by which
it judges them is open but okay there's
a criteria by which it judges its
criteria and so on none of those are
fixed that's another thing that I think
we do know about how the mind works it's
not hierarchical that's another thing
which another mistake that I think the
the AI and Alignment concept makes the
idea is that
when
the AGI or let's go back to
a chess playing a unit an AI when an AI
chess player makes a move it's because
it had calculated that if it makes the
move and then somebody else makes a move
and it makes a move and the other player
makes a move and so on and then it works
its way back by a long chain of
reasoning to its fundamental motivation
which doesn't change it never thinks oh
I'd rather play checkers instead
which is more realistic I don't so much
care about winning I love the game I
want to have a good game many chess
players would rather have a good game
than win the people who are trying to
become world champion don't think like
that but it's maybe not very nice to not
think like that and often they quit
because
winning as the ultimate goal is not as
pleasant as having a good game as the
ultimate goal is
one of several mistakes made by
alignment people is the idea of a
hierarchy of motivation so first of all
we've got to make sure that the basic
motivation can't be reinterpreted as
making paper clips according to them
and also we've got to make sure that in
this fundamental motivation is what we
think of as being a good person
not being a criminal
and I don't think it works like that at
all it couldn't possibly work like that
because if it did work like that it
couldn't be an AGI because it wouldn't
be General but I think even in practice
Minds aren't anywhere remotely like that
any idea
can be the basis of a conflict which
leads to a criticism of any other idea
of even of a different type so we may
think that the world is
three-dimensional and a base euclidean
geometry and so on and so
Emmanuel Kant thought that that was
built into our brains
so this
idea that's built into our brains
could come into conflict with our ideas
of how gravity works
nobody could have predicted that but
it's trivial that if you don't like the
look of a theory
then that's already
a conflict between ideas which you have
to settle by conjecture criticism or you
know you might not settle it there are
ways of thinking that don't settle
things and which which lead to
unhappiness and frustration and there's
no guarantee of settling things even if
one does
do the right thing but Papa said that
the good life is to fall in love with
the problem and live with it happily for
the rest of your life
and if it should happen this is in his
autobiography if you should happen to
solve it and he's kind of saying that as
if you know that's a bit of an
unfortunate thing if you happen to solve
it but don't worry there will be problem
children
a series of enchanting problem children
as he put it
so
an idea about how you want to live can
conflict with an idea about
what the laws of physics are can
conflict with an idea of what you think
the law should say about copyright every
one of these ideas can become a source
of criticism to the others and there's
only one thing to do a general thing to
do about this so as an example I think
you've mentioned this also where we had
an idea that the universe or the sun
revolved around the earth and then that
changed too well the Earth revolves
around the Sun but the solar system is a
center and then no no that's a part of a
galaxy and you know that's part of a
universe and no no that's part of a
Multiverse and each one of those changes
your view of the role of humans in
existence in reality so the common
conception has been well Evolution
showed us that we came here from
tadpoles and frogs and monkeys and so
we're not that different we're not that
special we're just sort of improvements
on them and now with this expanded view
of the universe we see the universe is
much much larger and humans are like
this tiny little bacteria or scum that's
just populated backwards little planet
and so our epistemology about humans and
their role in the universe has changed
as our understanding of the physics has
changed but surprisingly you've taken
that back in the opposite direction
you've said well actually this is the
only general intelligence that we know
of and knowledge is this very powerful
thing so humans do have a very outsized
role to play and you had a great talk
that I think was titled something like
chemical scum that dream of distant
quasars and so could you please talk a
little bit about that what is the role
of humans as you understand it in The
Theory of Everything with what we know
today and how is it different and
special
what we know of the universe
at the moment
is the universe in the past everything
we see is in the past and the deeper we
look into the universe the deeper into
the past we look and if the universe is
going to last a long time you know it
may last an infinite time or the
theories that say it's going to last a
finite time that time is very very large
and in either case
what we see of the universe is very very
untypical accordingly
the way I know nowadays put this
is that
in the past
there's been a kind of
rule of thumb in the universe which I
call the hierarchy rule which is that
massive energetic things
strongly affect
less massive less energetic things but
not vice versa so if a comet strikes the
sun then the comet is completely
destroyed but the sun hardly notices
and if it weren't for this rule if it
weren't for this hierarchy rule
physics would be much much more
difficult because we then
couldn't understand a star unless we
knew what its planets were doing and we
couldn't understand what its planets
were doing unless we also understood
what meteors hit the planet and so on so
the fact that big things could be
affected by small things then they could
also be affected by small details of
themselves and we couldn't understand
much at all without knowing lots of
detail
in reality we could understand a lot
about astronomy without even knowing
that many of the things out there even
exist and it's the same with small
things
we can understand
why crystals this is a very nice part of
the history of Science by the way you
look at a crystal and you see that the
faces are at certain angles to each
other how do you explain those angles
well it's with the atomic theory they
explain that the different ways that
atoms can be stacked before we'd anyone
had ever seen an atom or knew what the
atoms were so there's a rule of thumb
the hierarchy rule that large things are
not affected by small things it's not a
law of nature it is an accidental
feature of the very early universe that
is to say the universe kind of up to now
but the hierarchy rule has already been
broken
four billion years ago by the emergence
of life
the emergence of life
was really
an event that happened in a single
molecule
never mind the emergence of life because
the thing that really violated the
hierarchy rule was the emergence of
photosynthesis
so photosynthesis is a mutation of a
gene for an earlier type of
photosynthesis that did not produce
oxygen
and was less efficient
but the oxygen producing photosynthesis
was a mutation
that mutation happened in one molecule
one DNA molecule and that molecule
went on to change the entire surface of
the Earth the entire atmosphere was
converted from carbon dioxide to oxygen
and all the substances on the surface of
the Earth were converted as well
some of them into
minerals all the iron ore on the surface
of the planet is thought to have been
created by the oxygen in the atmosphere
interacting with other materials on the
surface of the Earth so this one
molecule
has utterly transformed the whole
surface of the planet
which is something like 10 to the 40
times its mass
so
somebody looking at the Earth from the
other side of the Galaxy and seeing that
oxygen form
could know that the hierarchy rule has
been violated on Earth that's sort of an
amazing amount
of violation but that's nothing compared
with what
people can do
with what explanatory creativity can do
because
biological evolution is severely limited
in its ability to create knowledge
it can only create knowledge where every
step
every slight change to the existing
knowledge is itself an improvement or at
least
not a disadvantage this limits what
biological evolution can do if you think
about say humans inventing fire sorry it
wasn't invented by humans it was
invented by some precursor species who
were also people
so those people invented fire and it was
terribly useful it would have been
useful to many other species as well but
they never evolved it probably because
there was no sequence of steps
Each of which was advantageous
whereas a human with creative
imagination
can see let's say a burning branch
left over from a forest fire or
something like that and can think
it's getting late you know they've been
on a hunting trip we might not get home
before it gets dark which would be
terrible life-threatening
but maybe if we take that Branch it will
light our way home
now that Hunter
can have that thought and can go and
reach for the branch
because he can creatively imagine that
he will survive and benefit from it
Evolution can't creatively imagine all
the changes it makes are before
the natural selection which makes the
genes better
so it's the other way around it's the
other way around for people everything
is the other way around for people so my
other favorite example is the aliens who
are watching us would see is that they
would eventually see
an asteroid heading towards the Earth
and then being deflected
and they would know that not only does
that violate the hierarchy rule but it
couldn't be done by just by Evolution
which also violates the hierarchy rule
but people violate it by an enormous
Factor more
so as I said in I think it was in a TED
Talk that once
humans have reached a factor of 10 to
the 40 of violating the hierarchy rule
we will be controlling the Galaxy
and
if you take that a bit further
that means that astrophysics
will become more and more
the history
of what people do
at the moment
when we look at an astronomical event we
don't take into account what people do
but by the time we've reached that
factor of 10 to the 40 you won't be able
to tell what the star will do unless you
know something about what people will do
so in this model humans become Central
to the universe they're not a sideshow
yeah people knowledge these things all
go along together
I found an amazing quote
from the 19th century by an Italian
geologist called
Antonio stoppani thinkis Antonio and he
he wrote a Geology book and he said that
the final layer you know he was talking
about all the layers of and the ages in
the the history of the Earth
and he said I have no hesitation in
calling this he said the anthropogenic
era nowadays it's called the
anthropocene era and it's used as a term
of abuse as if you know the anthropocene
is the era during which humans destroy
everything but stoppani
was pleased with the anthropocene as we
would say
and he wrote a beautiful passage about
how this is a a new law of nature that
is on the same par on the par with the
laws of gravity and you will I forget
what he said I could look it up on my
computer if you're interested you could
also put it in the show notes yeah we
can put in the show notes so so in this
model humans are Central to the universe
you're not going to understand the
universe without understanding humans
people or minds or whatever succeeds us
because the knowledge that we create
knowledge can travel from one planet to
another and transform it completely and
utterly violating this hierarchy rule of
thumb that we've seen in the old
universe and I think you've defined
knowledge or you've said that one of the
principles of knowledge is that
knowledge is a thing that causes self to
be replicated in the environment because
it is useful so knowledge can live
inside our DNA in our genes and the
genes that are correct and useful get
replicated not just in the universe but
possibly even in the Multiverse and as
an aside one beautiful output of that
that I saw in one of your books was that
if you were to look at there's lots of
ways to be wrong but there's only a few
ways to be right or there's certainly
less ways to be right than there are to
be wrong and because the ways that are
right are likely to be copied if you
were able to peek at the entire
Multiverse at once you would see truth
as a thing that is repeated across the
Multiverse so I took that in a fanciful
way as a meaning of life which is I want
to be the version of myself that is
successful in the most instances of the
Multiverse yeah because that contains
the most truth we want to be multiversal
crystals
yes the closer you are to the truth the
more of you that exists in the
Multiverse in a very odd way so there's
your practical application of Multiverse
Theory combined with epistemology but
out of this also came all kinds of other
interesting outputs I really encourage
people to read the beginning of infinity
at least the first three chapters which
I think are an easy read before you even
get in the physics part where you talk
about wealth and resources can you give
us your definition of wealth and then as
a follow-up to that I think naturally
comes are we running out of resources
the wells is not a number I don't think
it can be characterized very well by a
number it is a set
the set of all transformations that you
are capable of bringing about
that is your wealth
and obviously if optimism is true then
there's no limit to wealth
and at any one time
there is a rough correlation
between
the wealth that is the
set of all transformations that you
could bring about and other things that
aren't very fundamental like the amount
of money you have or the amount of
energy you control or the amount of land
you control or the amount of power you
have and so on but those are
not fundamental they are all outgrown
eventually by the growth of knowledge so
at the moment if you have a lot of goals
you can bring things about by
exchanging the goals for knowledge that
other people have if you want a painting
of yourself you can hire a painter to
make the painting of yourself even if
you couldn't
but in the long run
gold won't do that because in the long
run some other knowledge that is growing
will be able to get gold from an
asteroid and then gold will become
cheaper and cheaper and cheaper
and artists will no longer accept gold
ultimately
what they will accept and it's also true
today because the economy is a rather
imperfect
way of
accounting
for knowledge creation
it's true that it's rather imperfect so
people can acquire money and power and
so on sometimes without creating much
knowledge but again in the long run
that is not true
so in the long run the only thing you
could pay the artist with
would be
more knowledge kind of knowledge that
he's not good at
creating
and I love how deep this explanation is
I love the reach of it because it also
applies at the civilizational level as a
civilization figures out how to make
more and more Transformations everybody
gets wealthier wealth is a byproduct of
knowledge and because we can do anything
and figure anything that's not
constrained by the laws of physics that
wealth is unlimited just like knowledge
is unlimited and even things that before
were not considered wealth we can
transform into sources of wealth through
new knowledge so this idea has
tremendous reach much deeper than I
think even just the first definition
implies if one thinks it through and as
somebody who personally spent a lot of
time thinking through wealth creation it
was staggering to me how good of a
definition this was to the point where I
replaced my previous definitions with
this one yeah
that's nice to hear yeah
when you have an idea let's say you're a
geologist or something you have an idea
about geology suddenly your idea has
converted
some rocks into a resource
and you haven't even touched it yet The
Rock has been converted into resource
without anyone ever touching it just the
idea in the mind of somebody has
converted the rock into a resource and
we have just mentioned asteroids
somebody thought of mining asteroids
nobody's mind an asteroid yet but they
have already made asteroids more
valuable just by thinking of that
yeah it's like a solar power is
basically a set of ideas that converts
sunlight into an energy resource form
that's usable by humans before it was
only usable at plants through
photosynthesis the discovery of fire
turned wood into a resource nuclear
fission turn uranium into a resource and
so resources are things that we create
through knowledge rather than some
finite static fixed set of things that
we've burned through and abuse and use
up
yes and before anyone had those ideas
the objects the physical objects in
question obeyed the hierarchy rule but
as soon as you have that knowledge it
was the other way around the hierarchy
Rule people turn everything the other
way around it's the instead of massive
energetic things dominating less massive
less energetic things
it's things with more meaning to
dominate things with less meaning things
with more knowledge dominate things with
less knowledge or you know hopefully no
knowledge
because we don't want to dominate people
David on your homepage of your website
you've mentioned thinkers you admire and
you list off a number in amps Carl
popper Michael Faraday William Godwin
Thomas McCauley if I'm getting the
pronunciation right and Richard Feynman
I'm curious to know
if you were to recommend to a listener
who does not have any physics background
to perhaps educate themselves study
two or three of these to begin who might
you suggest they start with
Faraday his physics is kind of obsolete
the only thing you would learn from
Faraday is how to be a physicist
and he was an amazing physicist
if you want to learn actual physics you
wouldn't do it from Faraday you might do
it from Feynman but even Feynman is a
bit out of date now
the physics that I would really you know
if I didn't know any physics now and I
wanted to learn some I would want to
learn quantum physics and unfortunately
there is no good book on quantum physics
for beginners I hope to write one but
there's a lot of things I hope to write
I'm kind of negotiating writing a
textbook with some colleagues
they have to earn their daily bread as
well zooming out a bit from your
question
rather than wanting to have learned
something
I would recommend
studying or beginning to go into
something that looks interesting
so you know you can look up those four
names on Wikipedia and you will find
that Macaulay was a historian and
politician and
so on and Feynman was a Maverick
physicist and so on
and then something that I might make you
want to know more you know how could it
be how could it be that
you have a problem how could it be that
a person like that becomes recognized as
having made great discoveries
so then you can look further and look
further and look further people who
read my books
we'll find in the back
of each of my two books there's a list
of books that you might like you know if
you like this you might like these
and I don't believe in curricula
I don't believe in set subjects or in
narrow subjects something that interests
you is going to be the way to find out
what you should be learning so what
David is saying here is also part of his
core philosophy that there's an output
of his philosophy called taking children
seriously which applies this curiosity
driven framework and kind of freedom to
explore to child raising and I do
encourage people to look that up
separately that is a podcast in and of
itself I will say I would not have been
able to understand the books and get
into them as easily as well if it
weren't for the tireless work of Brett
Hall he runs a podcast called the theory
of knowledge podcast talkcast t-o-k cast
and he's got 100 episodes in there that
literally goes through David's books
chapter by chapter and explains with
lots of examples and very carefully for
the layperson to kind of catch up on a
lot of the ideas in those books also I
started reading popper after
encountering David's work and popper has
a lot of books the open Society audience
enemies the logic of scientific
discovery etc etc but for people who are
just starting out those can be a little
dense because he's arguing with other
philosophers and popper is very good
about steel Manning arguments so he
takes the other people very seriously
and that takes time and so if you're not
a professional philosopher you just want
to figure out epistemology there's a
recent book that I found called
philosophy in the real world which is
like a little hundred page introduction
to Carl popper by Brian Mcgee and I
found that to be a good lighter weight
introduction bound to be good if it's by
him
yeah there is a lot of good stuff out
there I'd say there now there's a good
set of people who have been influenced
Enough by these ideas and realize that
it forms a core of a world view which
goes by the name critical rationalism
although we should be careful of all
isms for the obvious reasons we're all
valuable but the the critical
rationalist group has started putting
together both reading materials
explanatory materials there's a website
for taking children seriously there's a
critical rationalism newsletter out
there and people are putting all of this
stuff to talk cast I think is still the
go-to for easy comprehension of a lot of
these ideas but I still tell people look
the beginning of the beginning of
infinity the first three chapters are
actually not a very difficult read the
ideas might be hard to swallow because
they do violate a lot of core deeply
held beliefs that people have but they
return power to the individual and in a
strange way they do coincide with common
sense even though a lot of science has
explained the scene in terms of the
Unseen they do return you this common
sense of notion of actually maybe I can
understand the explanations that explain
everything that we know today maybe
humans are important and knowledge is
special and we aren't just these
bacterial scum that happen to
accidentally populate this planet in a
strange way it does align with your
everyday lived experience of reality and
I also recommend the last few chapters
of the book as an easy read because they
apply these principles to politics to
the memetic Warfare that goes on on
Twitter 24 7 and how that's evolving to
things like beauty is beauty objective
moral knowledge is there such a thing as
moral knowledge and can we objectively
make progress in moral knowledge so
these are very very fundamental
questions none of them involve math none
of them involve physics none of them
involve deep science although if you
understand even at a higher level the
physics then I think it will give you a
firmer foundation and understand that
all of these things weave together as an
aside I do think the fabric of reality
was a great name I'm glad you ended up
going with that one one because it is a
second thing besides not being as
grandiose of a claim it does say these
things are woven together and they
depend on each other so one leads to the
other leads to the other and even
Austrian economics is an output of what
you're talking about because Austrian
economics was creativity and knowledge
grows at the center of the economy so
then you can see how all of these things
sort of fit together as logical puzzle
pieces as opposed to a set of random
beliefs that you picked up because they
were convenient or taught to you or
aligned with your motivations yes indeed
David just one final question for me
which is from some time ago the context
this is from edge.org from 2004 but
there are a number of things that I
found on this website one of which was
Deutsch's law every problem that is
interesting is also soluble
and we could spend quite a bit of time
unpacking that and I'm happy certainly
to listen to you expand on that but I'm
simply wondering what problems are most
interesting to you personally right now
I am working on a new
Theory and physics called Constructor
Theory
and it is to me amazing
and one of the problems I have is how to
explain to other people why it is
amazing
and what's good about it and this is one
of the things that you have to do later
because the early part of
understanding something new like
creating something new is to understand
it yourself
and the construct theory has already
changed a lot since I first thought of
it and we're beginning to have
theoretical applications of it
not yet practical applications but you
know one day there will be Universal
Constructors
and Universal Constructors are to
construct a theory what Universal
computers are to theory of computation
so Constructor theory is the theory of
all things that can be done
and can't be done in the distinction
between things that can be done and
can't be done considered as ethereal
physics so you reformulate physics to
make statements entirely about that what
can and can't be done
and then you know Naval you will like
the economic implications you know some
people think that once we have Universal
Constructors you realize that Universal
Constructor can make more Universal
Constructors and then you have
exponentially more of them as time goes
on so there'll be no role for humans
anymore but the exact opposite is true
as usual the universal Constructors are
like just like a universal computer is
perfectly obedient it is obedient humans
are disobedient you need the disobedient
things to program the obedient things so
I spoke a while ago about the fact that
gold is eventually going to be cheap
because
machines will go out to the asteroids
and mine the Gold and those machines
once we have Universal Constructors they
will be made
by other machines and those machines
will be made by and so on and eventually
everything will be made by Universal
instructors and what will people do
well
toil physical toil will be abolished
because
that can be done by robots that can be
built by other robots that can be and so
on right down to the universal
Constructor
but when I say can be
they will have to be programmed to be
and if you want something done
either you will download from the
internet a program where someone has
already worked out how to you know make
a perfect robot Butler or whatever but
if you want something new done that
hasn't been done before and you will
then you have to write the program for
it
or
hire someone to write the program for it
but then he will want a program in
return
there's a Kelvin Hobbes where Calvin has
this box that becomes a universal
Constructor and he starts making copies
of himself so he turns the box upside
down he opens it up another Calvin comes
out and so he commands this Calvin to do
his homework and then he creates another
Calvin and that Calvin has to go and do
his chores and sure enough what he ends
up with is a whole bunch of calvins who
are all playing video games and eating
food and none of them actually want to
do the chores of the homework because
these are the agis these are calvins and
so yes disobedience is a big one I will
say your your philosophies have a huge
difference for me on child raising and I
have now realized that it is more
important even through this conversation
it is more important that I have a
disobedient child than an obedient child
or an educated or learn it or whatever I
may think is the right set of things
because it is fundamentally that
Disobedience that allows the creativity
to come up with new ideas and it's that
creativity that separates us from the
robots and the auto batons and all of
the other things that the universe is
full of
inly enlightenment
a few philosophers and other people
realize that this is true of politics
you know previously
people thought the problem of politics
is who should command everyone else who
should Rule and the more obedient people
are to that the better because if you've
got the right person ruling
then all you need for the rest of the
society is for everyone to do what he
says if they don't do what he says then
the society is imperfect in the
enlightenment people realized that is
not what we want
we want to make it so that as much as
possible people aren't ruled
and to the extent that we have not yet
completely abolished ruling
Society is still imperfect we haven't
got enough knowledge of how to reduce
power
political power in society but we've
done very very well compared with only a
few hundred years ago when Not only was
power everywhere but people thought that
was the way of things people thought
that that's how things had to be and the
only issue was what should the power
make people do
and this leads a little bit to what you
have called a moral imperative which is
don't destroy the means of error
correction in fact the only time I think
in your book that you let a little
emotion slip through I would say is when
you're addressing exactly this topic
when you said if we should take it
personally because if people hadn't
stopped the growth of knowledge in the
past like has often happened through
anti-rational memes or censorship or
religion or through just any sort of
belief system even believe in science
use as a religious invocation if people
hadn't done that then you and I might be
I think it is your quote you and I might
be immortal and we might be exploring
the stars and so we should take it
personally yes I may have said too much
on it but I would love to hear your
extrapolation on it
I do take it personally and and as far
as the I thought you were going to say
when I said that that's the moral
imperative that not destroying the means
of error correction is the moral
imperative I thought you were going to
say that's the only place in the book
where I actually tell people what to do
but I I don't because I put that into
the mouth of a fictional character it's
in a little play that's in the book and
it's the character that says that not me
you know the character is Socrates so I
I'm doing what Plato did I put my ideas
into the mouth of Socrates and then I
don't have to take responsibility for it
so I'm not telling people but
if they destroy the means of error
correction they'll regret it well David
I know we're coming up on about two
hours now I want to be respectful of
your time we've covered a lot of ground
uh Naval is there anything you would
like to ask before we begin to wind at
least this first conversation to a close
I think this is a great conversation I
think we covered a lot of the
introductory topics again I think
there's no substitute for reading the
books and you know these are books that
will make you smarter you'll have to go
slowly and just read them and reread
them I find every time I read them I get
new things out of them a lot of times
there are outputs of the world view that
are stated in one or two sentences that
you don't appreciate until the third or
fourth reading and there's no points for
finishing there's no points for reading
an order there's no points for going
quickly it's just about understanding if
you want to understand the world around
you better and make better decisions I
can't recommend it more highly I've
spent a lot of my time and effort on
letting people know what I got out of
them and I hope they will likewise and
we'll put more thing things in the show
notes we didn't really get to cover
Constructor Theory which is David's new
theory that actually it unites a lot of
different pieces of physics including
puts information and knowledge at the
center so I know that his colleague
Kiara marletto wrote a great book the
science of Canon Cat that tries to
explain it to the layperson there's a
great science writer Logan chipkin who's
been doing some work on it and he is a
good interview with Kiara so we can put
all that in the show notes there's an
infinite Rabbit Hole here to go down and
thank you Naval for helping to organize
this and I was very happy to sit in the
passenger seat to learn as much as I
have in the conversation I've taken
copious notes and I've just learned so
much in the process of doing homework
for this conversation so thank you for
your work and time David David is there
anything else you would like to add any
closing comments requests of the
audience anything at all
I think there are things to read other
than my books Papa you know what you
just said about reading my books I find
that with popper in fact it's rather
embarrassing sometimes
I come across something which I thought
was my idea I always say that all I've
done is added footnotes to Papa and
Turing and so on
and sometimes I read a passage of proper
and I think to myself oh my God he knew
he already knew and you only get it
after having read it several times
so I recommend popper and Macaulay is a
completely different it seems completely
different when you read Macaulay he's a
19th century historian and he wrote this
history of England which he died halfway
through writing it so he only covers
like the first few hundred years and
then the really interesting things are
just beginning and he somebody tried to
complete it using his notes and it's
nowhere near as good it doesn't have the
thing but if you read Macaulay
like you were just saying about
understanding the world you read
Macaulay you understand history it's not
really a history of England it
masquerades as a history of England but
it's a philosophy of History
I recommend him
well lots of ground covered many many
things to add to the show notes which
people will be able to find at tim.blog
podcast as per usual David thank you so
much for making time today especially
given how much later it is across the
pond really appreciate it you're welcome
it's fun and thank you Naval once again
and to everybody listening really
appreciate of course all the time in
your ears and as I mentioned already we
will add notes for everything we
referenced in the conversation and
Beyond in the show notes Tim dot Blog
podcast until next time thanks for
tuning in
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet Friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog Friday type that into your
browser Tim dot blog slash Friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by ag1 by
athletic greens a true staple of my
daily routine as it has been for more
than a decade I take it most mornings
and I even travel with it whether I'm
skiing traveling abroad going to an
event where I'll be around a lot of
people I just use it to cover all of my
nutritional bases but let's start with
the basics what is ag-1 and we'll get to
the ingredients but I get asked all the
time what I would take if I could only
take one supplement the answer is
invariably ag1 and as I mentioned I view
it as my all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it long ago in
my 2010 number one New York Times
bestseller the four hour body and I did
not get paid to do so with approximately
75 vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients you'd be very
hard-pressed to find a more nutrient
dense formula on the market I know how
much time they put into quality
assurance and sourcing it has a
multivitamin a multi mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immune support formula
digestive enzymes and adaptogens I
always do my best of course to get
nutrient-rich meals and that is a top
priority but ag-1 makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when good Whole Foods
simply aren't at hand or when you just
want to ensure you are covering your
bases
furthermore it's also NSF certified for
sport making it safe for professional
athletes as what's on the label is
actually what's in the powder ag1 is the
ultimate all-in-one nutritional
supplement bundle in one easy scoop
because let's face it if it's not
convenient you're just not going to use
it and athletic greens is giving you a
free one-year supply of vitamin D and
five free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase go to athletic
greens.com Tim you can check it out one
more time actually two more times
athleticreens.com Tim they also offer a
90-day money-back guarantee if you are
not 100 satisfied learn more try it out
athleticgreens.com Tim
this episode is brought to you by
freshbooks when you're running your own
business it is easy to get weighed down
by work that does not get you paid
that's why I love fresh books and have
been recommending it for years on this
podcast freshbooks makes managing your
money and your business easier from Easy
invoicing to time saving automations
freshbooks simplifies accounting and
bookkeeping and ensures you're ready for
tax time freshbooks was built for
business owners and accounting
professionals it is simple simple based
on a benefit survey of more than 10 000
freshbooks customers you can save up to
11 hours a week by streamlining and
automating bookkeeping and accounting
tasks like time tracking invoicing and
expense tracking you can also create
professional branded invoices in minutes
more than 30 million people have used
freshbooks and love it for its intuitive
dashboard and reports it's easy to see
at a glance exactly where your business
stands and it's even easier to turn
everything over to your account income
tax season 94 of freshbooks users say
it's super easy to get up and running
and with award-winning support you are
never alone freshbooks is the all-in-one
accounting software that can save you up
to 11 hours per week that's 11 hours
they get freed up so you can spend more
time nailing a client pitch serving your
customers or honing your craft and right
now there's a special offer just for you
my dear listeners head over to
freshbooks.com Tim to get 90 off of your
freshbook subscription for four months
that's freshbooks.com Tim one more time
check it out learn more and get 90 off
of your subscription for four months at
freshbooks.com Tim
[Applause]